oh
what
look at that sneeze guard in full effect
welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm
mark bernard hey
hello uh here we are back at the skelem
and villainy cantina
on hollywood boulevard in hollywood
california not that you know it out
there right now it's pretty quiet
it is a little bit ghost towny out there
today well it's the holiday weekend
it is for everyone but us because we're
muckraking
do you think people are like in their
houses where they're supposed to be
without anybody else there or at their
some [ __ ] party somewhere
who's who could party in this weather i
don't know what it's like in the rest of
the world but
[ __ ] 103 degrees today
supposed to be 109 tomorrow it was 118
out by me what yes oh
so hot that when i walked outside i felt
the hair on my legs start to sizzle
ew yeah unbelievable didn't
i like hurt it faintly in the distance
like what is that is that bacon
no that's you fool get in the car oh
so damn hot um and now you know a lot of
fear about
rolling brownouts or blackouts because
everybody's got their [ __ ] acs on
uh rightfully so now is the time to turn
that [ __ ] i've been sacrificing small
animals and livestock to my air
conditioning unit simply so that it
keeps going
because oh god oh sweet ball
i'm not sure i'm having god of the bible
please make sure that the air
conditioner don't crap out
yeah it's been nasty man nasty but we're
here in a very chilly
uh it's coming villainy cantina thanks
to jc for coming in early turning the
air conditioner on
so that we could sit here in comfort and
give you the
[ __ ] news i'm a little bitter because
all i want to do is eat and i'm not
eating today
oh are we gonna say so this will this
will substitute for eating
indeed our sponsor for this episode is
doordash
i know which will bring food to you if
you want it unless you don't ask for it
this is the cruelest ad a man in the
midst of a fast
should have to read ladies and gentlemen
but today's
episode of fat man beyond is sponsored
as mark says by the good
folks at doordash man right now our
listeners can get
five bucks off and zero delivery fees on
their first order
of 15 bucks or more when you download
the doordash app
and enter the code fat man take it
get fatter you know you wanna that's
five bucks off your and zero five bucks
off at zero delivery fees
on your first order ladies and gentlemen
when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter the code all
one word
fat man f-a-t-m-a-n don't forget that
code's fat man
for five bucks off your first order with
doordash
um i actually used doordash this week
did you what'd you guys
uh my kid it was a place called
[ __ ] it was a pizza joint and
my kid like threw it under my nose go
i'm ordering from here
and she sent me a link and i clicked on
the link and it was the doordash
version of it i said you ordering
doordash she said yeah i was like oh we
do ads for them
use the code yeah i was like there's a
pocket code what is it i can't remember
it
for the life of me we didn't get our
monies off and stuff um but man
they come they bring the food they leave
it right on the doorstep
contact free delivery contact free
delivery which in these covety times
that's what you're looking for man
hell yeah contact freedom in reading
these copy points which you know
the the handy folks at doordash will
give you things to talk about and there
was one on here that i didn't read last
time
i didn't notice they have over 300 000
partners in the u.s puerto rico canada
and australia it's a lot of restaurants
that's a lot of restaurants so like if
you're in the mood for anything
they can probably find a guy to bring it
to you movies might be on doordash for a
long time
um i mean you could go anywhere right
they'll take you anywhere
pretty much anywhere you want to eat
what are you feeling like having some
chinese feeling like having some
mexicans some cubans some native america
they have native american cuisine
i'm sure they do but i'm not sure if you
can
maybe i'm wrong a restaurant like a full
a full-on like hopi restaurant something
like that i bet you right
if not you and me invest in open heavens
that's untouched
untouched uncharted territories
restaurant uh they can get you anything
man
they'll bring it right to you and then
you'll be chowing down something that i
would
love to be doing right now let me tell
you something i'd give my
soul to have a doordash beyond burger
delivered to me from veggie girl
right now but temperance kids
indeed and migrants don't do it for us
it'd be very kind i feel like soupy
sales like do not
send us a dollar i asked you last
episode to send us a dollar
care of this was it sid caesar i forget
where no that was super sad was it too
easy
um i uh i forget sometimes that we are
alive that's right and some
kind uh stranger out there might be like
i'm gonna send that dude to
a beyond burger don't do it he doesn't
want it don't i don't want it that's the
problem
i want it so much but i'm gonna wait and
stuff um so hey but
you know what you know who don't have to
wait you
you want to eat like a normal human
being unlike a broken individual like i
am
you go to doordash and order right now
ladies and gentlemen
don't forget that code fat man for five
bucks off
wall one word your first order with
doordash
and zero delivery fees come on you ain't
gonna get a better deal than that
all night long it's saturday night
you're hungry you want to party
hit up doordash right you got the
munchies they'll take care of you
i envy you i envy you
um all right get let me take my mind off
eating
excellent i've been watching things as
have i
have you i have yeah [ __ ] god bless
these streamers
who are like oh it's labor day weekend
let's drop everything [ __ ] early
i am fully up to date on lovecraft
country which includes
the episode they just dropped i haven't
seen it before oh
i haven't seen the fourth one it's
raiders the lost ark
kick ass is really wonderful stuff um
there is a uh new
series on hbo by ridley scott
called raised by wolves oh on the hbo
max on hbo max
is that so that's not on hbo not on hbo
oh
i don't know that so you couldn't i
couldn't watch it if i just decided
if you were just terrestrially watching
[ __ ] you can't do it it's
[ __ ] fantastic oh my god
it feels like 70s sci-fi but not 70
sci-fi movies
like omni magazine story or something
deep science and big think and
[ __ ] it's good man it's really good
surprisingly good i don't know who the
cat is that wrote it but
very talented created this thing but
ridley scott has directed all three
episodes that they dumped on hbo max
as a preview like here's three so you
can watch three hours of this
[ __ ] thing yeah that's smart it's
beautiful looks like a masterpiece in
the making i've enjoyed
the [ __ ] out of it they also dropped on
hbo
um you've been watching this documentary
the vow i've seen the first two
did they drop another episode they just
dropped another one yeah like the first
episode was like
okay all right like i s whatever this
just seems like a daffy self-help thing
okay
sure and oh there's a lot of battle star
people in here that's weird
but all right oh my god of course you
would be interested yeah like
huh all right i've interviewed some of
these people i've met some of these
people
never interviewed that lady but whatever
and then the second episode
it starts to turn and you're like oh oh
yeah
no here's the freaky sex [ __ ] that we
kept on hearing about
well that this episode that's where they
really start getting into it
and then the next episode as well and
this current episode they just put up
like either yesterday or today the one
that would have went up sunday but they
dropped it early
um gets into the into the branding stuff
i mean i ain't judging anybody
but how many times let me tell you why
i'm gonna judge them right now
how many times watching this have you
been like
and you didn't see that as a warning
sign
like the one girl's talking about like
you know they're [ __ ]
cauterizing my flesh like i smell
burning flesh and this woman screaming
convulsing and stuff
that like you know i know look some
people need
like self-help i went to a self-help
course at my sister's behest once called
the landmark forum
it was based on the technology
from est which was the 70s
like self-esteem program
earhart seminar training this guy named
warner erhard came up with the same kind
of [ __ ]
where it's just like you know you are in
charge of your own
you can't be a victim because you blah
blah blah
not that different from tony robbins and
stuff like that
so i went to this landmark forum thing
and their big pitch was
like you know you're there for a
three-day course you give us three days
we'll break you and remake you
and i'll be honest with you some of the
[ __ ] they taught me still like kind of
functions somewhere in me
today it was useful stuff um but these
cats weren't like
culty but if they had said to me like
cultist things that like i heard at
landmark forum was
when we graduated they're like you got
to invite three people and i'm like all
right well
i get it like [ __ ] you want to make
more money i understand you're right
but if somebody had been like and now we
want you to be naked
and we're going to brand your flesh like
that's when you raise like that's when
you run run like [ __ ] man
and i mean i don't pay much attention to
tony robbins beyond like you know
seeing him in on tv or whatnot but
he has a similar kind of you are
empowered i will help empower you
i don't think he's branded people though
either it's so strange what becomes a
cult and what doesn't
well i mean i i think it's always like
who
won like who's in the majority if you're
in the majority you're not a cult
anymore
yeah like you're a full-on religion
welcome to the party everybody it's true
uh but if you're still on the fringes
and you're still clawing your way in
then it's
and you're a little bit outside of like
okay if you're going to church you
expect a certain number of things
at that service but if you're going to
nexium
then like we're just going to talk about
actualizing yourself and we're just
going to have conversations about
you know encountering your your inner
blocks and we're going to figure out
ways to liberate you from your
preconceived notions of the world and
so forth and so on i know you also got
to pay a lot of money to be in this and
that will make you a proctor and then
you'll
have to pay even more money to stay in
this and then then
you'll get to have one-on-ones with the
guy who knows the [ __ ]
and and the one guy the pope of the [ __ ]
keith
they had people calling him vanguard
like that was his nickname vanguard
like happy birthday vanguard and stuff
like that um
i ain't saying the truth can't be found
in a small hotel ballroom
but i added a fair number of small hotel
boxes i have
and that's the thing that as i'm
watching this i'm like
none of these cats like smell what's
coming
next and also it's like is
truth and power gonna come from a couple
cats
in a hotel ballroom maybe possibly
yeah i mean ultimately it feels a lot
like you're buying a timeshare
very much you know like all of the
markers feel exactly the same of like
come down to this place that's kind of
lovely and see all of the awesome cool
[ __ ] you just owe us like an hour to sit
and listen this presentation if you
decide to buy
in boca a thing that you're going to go
to once a year and never go back to
again and it's going to cost you a lot
of money and you'll never get the
full utilization of that money but if
that sounds like a good idea come on
down we learn
put your name on this list this glenn
gary list as well
we'll reach out to you for all sorts of
promotions yeah i
i uh there's never been a bone in my
body that thought that any of that was a
good idea
i just have you ever needed to be led so
[ __ ] badly
that you would be that led as these
people are like this is this one guy
who's the director of what the bleep do
we know mark vicente his name is
like you know my wife the whole time i'm
watching this she's like i feel bad for
that guy that guy's so earnest and he
like really believed in all this [ __ ]
and it is kind of like heartbreaking all
of them did like
not a one of them thought this was a
scam they all thought they were changing
the world
and that one dude devoted 12 years of
his life to it
like before suddenly the bottom dropped
out it's
it's crazy but it's a it's a fascinating
watch
i'm i'm too much of a mulder i think to
to to go in for that kind of stuff and
some people are
are [ __ ] scully's i'm sorry too much
of a scope vice versa yeah vice versa
he wants to believe he wants to believe
but you know and dives in whole heart
i'm i i'm by nature a skeptic so it's
like
but really though i wonder if those are
people that
didn't have like religion as kids
like i had the catholic church so
anybody comes like you know
going like i've got the answer i'm like
this ought to be good
because i've heard this before i heard
it from the best son
catholic church sold me so you gotta if
you're gonna come with like
i know how to make your life better like
your pitch has to be better than
than theirs they got jesus he was like a
rock star yeah i didn't have religion in
my life but i had star wars
so i felt like that also filled the bill
that's true you know like if you you
just need something to believe in
as daffy and ridiculous as this poison
used to say
give me something to believe in
i feel like working a poll yeah um it's
worth watching
it's definitely a good duck what else
have i watched oh the boys
i've seen the first two watched all
three they did they
amazon also did an early dump for this
labor day weekend and they put up three
episodes just
wonderful absolutely [ __ ] wonderful
man
i um thank god they do the recap video
right at the top
he's like what happened last year
because i was like oh [ __ ] i forgot that
oh [ __ ] i forgot oh [ __ ] i forgot that
but that's been great too and it just
got really [ __ ]
twisted in like episode three with the
storm front character now okay yeah
i'm still on you know i just finished
two and it's
it's a lot for me like i equated it to
john wick two and three compared to john
mc1 which is
i just like these characters and i like
this world but it doesn't
the the emotional hook is not there for
me as solid as it was
for the boys for the boys um it's early
yet but it's like oh all right sure i'll
watch
the homelander have the most [ __ ] up
scene with a glass of milk i think i've
ever seen
oh hello what was that
that was just i was like is that the
sound of a glass of milk sorry
but yeah like there's a scene where he's
just [ __ ] literally orgasming over
breast milk breast milk madeline's
breast milk yes
clearly um but yeah i'm just waiting for
the thing to kick in
right that that sort of pulls me through
it and for now it's a bunch of like
scenes with characters that i remember
having affinity for and
oh hey that's a new character that's
cool and hey that's some more characters
that's cool
hey there's pat and oswald's voice as
gills on on [ __ ] the deeps
like that's cool three is i think where
the plot starts
really kicking in gotcha i think you'll
you'll be like ah
that's where its head is now cool um but
yes
watch that and i think that's everything
i've watched
i watched uh i watched mulan today oh
[ __ ] did you
yes i did um i spent the 29.99 to get
premier access
to the picture for uh for as long as i'm
a disney plus subscriber i can watch
that movie
uh anytime i want as much as i want
uh in december it becomes it flips live
for everybody else
everybody gets it everybody for their
regular whatever price of disney plus
admission
um it's real good it's not great
like there are some characters that make
these kind of emotional turns that seem
kind of what she is
they're shot herself um but it's it's
it feels like a sort of
early 2000s it feels like house of
flying daggers it feels like hero it
feels a bit like crouching tiger
and that it's big and it's epic and they
shot it overseas looks
like they spent 12 or more yes very
expensive
very very expensive and it's got like
everybody who's anybody
in the chinese cinema like in this man
like gently is playing the emperor and
donnie yen is playing like her commander
and
gang lee is this witch and they didn't
put i didn't see jetley in the trailer
he's he's the emperor of china like he's
really yeah he's under like
some facial hair stuff going on and i
have to check the credits i'm like that
was gently that's cool
um it was um wasn't it what's his name
in the cartoon
pat morita i think he was the one that
plays the emperor
was he oh yeah that's cool there is no
mushu
there is no uh dragon sidekick i don't
know
um but you know yeah then again that was
added for
bucket disney that was invented for the
animated movie not part of the legend
right
at this point like 12 centuries old um
but yeah no the the turns of it
that i mean and you know what they are
right it's you've seen this movie you
know the story it's
she's pretending to be a a man for a
while and then something happens that
forces her to not do that
and so now she's gotta like kind of own
herself as a woman and
and all of that stuff is really
emotional when she finally saves the
emperor's life
spoilers sorry if you haven't seen this
movie
ever you know the homecoming where her
entire village now knows what she did to
save
you know not just herself and her her
men her cohorts
the emperor in china as a whole like
it's all really emotional and it all
really sticks the landing
um they add this element that feels a
little midichloriany
where they say oh her chi is much
stronger and
you shouldn't if you if you pretend to
be something you're not you will some
you'll subsume your chi and you won't be
everything you could be
um i'm like when suddenly she's magic
she didn't have she could just be
awesome yeah she's just brave right
yeah she just loves her family so much
brave does the right thing
but you know and smart super smart and
strategic
by warrior they added this other little
bit there that that
she's magic she's magic it is it is
in the same way the middle clients it's
answering a question that nobody had
right
which is oh how come she's so awesome
she just is
what um what uh
[Music]
did if it had come out in theaters
would it have been huge i think it would
have been massive
yeah yeah i mean i think it it it
scratches a lot of the same itches that
wonder woman scratches
right which is you know it's all about
kind of female liberation and
empowerment
there are sequences there's this one
sequence where
you know she she discovers that the big
bad guy
boracan who played by jason scott lee
who like i haven't seen in a
20 years like oh that [ __ ] guy he was
a bruce lee in the dragon movie that's
cool
um when he's going to take over you know
the [ __ ]
mainland china and is going after the
emperor itself and she's got to convince
everybody to come with her and she
and all of the male compatriots are like
i believe farmland
i believe on the line and it becomes
this very much like oh i believe women
and all these dudes are like i believe
her
it's like yeah no that would play much
differently
five years ago um yeah and it's
intentional and
i'm here for it um the action is really
good and it's
disney like they would have hammered it
into every kid's soul that they needed
to see this movie
and it's also a thing that parents could
see and much like crazy rich asians
there's an entire
you know culture that doesn't get to see
themselves like this on screens this big
who would have come out in force for it
so yeah it would have been a massive hit
why then put it on the streamer i think
because
they know to a certain degree that kids
are a big part of that audience
and parents who are fed up with being in
their house with their kids
i'm sure you all still love them i know
i love mine but six months is a long
time
like and we've seen trolls world tour 87
times we need something new
i think that's it is the we can
absolutely we'll know when did it go up
on friday
yeah friday the 4th so we'll probably
hear some figures on monday or tuesday
or something i think so how it did
you know but i i can't imagine that it
did poorly
um check this out and i'm sure you've
seen this
i saw this thing online today on twitter
and i absolutely loved it and i took a
screenshot of it
from a lady named mads i think a lady
light l-i-t-e and then underscore the
spark on
twitter um
put up a picture of uh ben kenobi
put up a picture of uh young ben kenobi
as played by even euan holding the two
twins
and then puts up a picture of luke and
leia in star wars
uh right as they're heading for the
falcon right before ben kenobi
gets killed by darth vader and she wrote
do you ever think about how the last
thing
obi-wan sees is luke and leia finally
reunited after 19 years
oh that's why i [ __ ] love social
media man i never would have thought of
that and this total [ __ ] stranger
just like made that all like that much
more beautiful well i'm like holy [ __ ]
and then i was sitting there going like
do you think he knew right
like did george lucas realize that or
was it just because he directed star
wars
and he directed you know [ __ ] revenge
of the sith
yeah i i don't know if he knew but
i think there's a way that you can say
when you're going back to do the
prequels
like adding freight that will make that
moment feel
differently than it had before it's like
oh [ __ ] we have this moment
what if it means this when before it was
just oh cool
luke and that girl who asked me to come
and save her okay
i guess they saved her yay but now it's
oh
these [ __ ] twins who've been
separated for 20 years that he had a
hand and
separated separated to save their lives
are now back together because of him
and now i can die happy let me tell you
something that tweet
as good as the mandalorian
you know what i'm saying in terms of
like how wonderful it made me feel about
star wars like when i read that tweet
i'm like
come the [ __ ] on that's beautiful man
like
it almost made me go back and watch star
wars again wow
just because i was like i'm gonna put it
through this [ __ ] filter of the old
man being like
all right i can rest now that's [ __ ]
beautiful that chokes me up a little bit
so give that [ __ ] person
a star wars movie totally you know what
i'm saying let that
that lady write a script break all our
hearts uh you know the other thing that
i did i spent
like three or four hours doing i was
playing marvel's new avengers video game
now yes
just hype me on the timeline because i'm
not a game guy
okay i remember they like put out a
trailer and everybody was like
this don't look like the characters is
that the same game
um probably because i near as i can tell
and if i had to guess they don't have
likeness rights right
to those people well they or they don't
want to pay like this
right they didn't want to pay the you
know king's ransom to get downey's face
right in this game so there's another
guy who's iron man and there's another
like kind of inamicably handsome
corn-fed blonde guy playing captain
america
right there's a weird collusion of like
ben affleck
and adam sandler as bruce banner
which is interesting like they just all
right let's put these two in a blender
and then put like a purple shirt on him
and now he's the hulk
um but it's it's it's a fun game like i
how does the game play and the gameplay
is super fun and the bad guy
is uh modoc right the bad guy eventually
is modoc i haven't gotten that far
thanks for spoiling the game for me kev
way to go no what i thought everybody
knew that
i'm [ __ ] with you just a little bit
um but the thing that's
that's most notable about this game for
me is that
the main character the the narrative
that we're following
is kamala khan's story it's miss marvel
it's marvel um and it's and it's it's
the
the becoming a hero story which is a a
tale as old as time
yeah you know and it opens with speaking
of luke skywalker speaking of luke
skywalker
um and it opens with this prequel where
you meet kamala i keep wanting to say
kamala because
you know i've been told time and time
again comma with the law
comma with allah but you meet
ms khan as a as a pre-teenager like and
she's on
she's on a helicarrier and it's like
avengers day and she's a super fan who
wrote a story and
one by one she meets all the avengers
and they all tell him i read your story
your story should be great and then like
crisis happens on the helicarrier and
[ __ ] goes bad and then flash forward 10
years later and
kamala khan is now trying to piece
together what has happened to the
avengers they seem to have vanished from
the scene
right and and it's it's this young woman
kind of coming into her own and learning
to embrace her power and learning to
embrace her differences and and her
innate biological strangeness while
still trying to believe in what the
avengers stood for when the world tells
her not to
um and kamala is important because you
know
not just is she a brand new character
that has been introduced by
to marvel but she is the first muslim
american you know
character in marvel who's a hero she's
pakistani american first generation
and and so to watch this character be
placed center stage and to
as a player have to live within that
skin and like
listen to languages you've never heard
and listened to terms of endearment
you've never heard before
it's a it's a it's a fundamentally
different experience than i've had
playing games before
um i don't know how it ends it could
[ __ ] the bed but
so far it's uh it's been kind of lovely
what's it for what systems
um i think it's for all of them at this
point ps4 um xbox one
i'm not sure if it's on the uh the
nintendo switch but i would bet that it
probably is
um and luckily enough tonight we get to
talk
to the actress who's playing kamala khan
who can tell us if i'm mispronouncing
the name
um sandra saad her name is uh we got
sandra coming in
was that her bleep bleep bleep flying in
right now
ladies and gentlemen to talk about the
avengers what's the game called avengers
marvel's avengers that's it that's it
like avengers
kodak goes mad um
we got her welcome uh welcome
to fat man beyond uh
sandra how are you hey guys it's an
honor to be here
oh well thank you for taking the time
honestly yeah taking time out of your
dairy carb loading uh to be with us
um mark knows i've been eating ice cream
all day because i'm also in l.a and it's
very very hot
so you do what you got to do you do what
you got to do
it was a nice pop kind of day in my
house as well
um so tell me first am i mispronouncing
the name
am i doing it right like i'm very
acutely aware
of kamala versus kamala right so the
the senator is kamala but um our girl
is kamala khan oh
excellent i don't feel like such a such
a loser
how did the role come into your life how
does this happen like how does one get
cast
in a video game um i didn't know it was
a video game
i've just been auditioning for you know
all kinds of film and tv
and all kinds of stuff and um i
this one casting director hit up another
casting director who hit up
uh bo crutcher who is our awesome
casting director
and he found me somehow um
and i auditioned and i auditioned again
and again and again and again
and when they are positively sure uh
they
they brought me on and then i learned
that i would be playing
miss muscle and marshall's avengers
who's the final person who has to say
yeah no she's the one
you know like i'm imagining there's some
star
chamber of animation marvel executives
behind
glass that's smoky and who say no it's
going to be her
um i don't know exactly how many people
are involved in that decision but i know
that it's probably
hundreds um the welcoming face that i
get to see first is like i said bo
and then our ketchup director and then i
get to see shawna skye
who's our director and um you know of
course
he's the one who gets to really really
make a big decision there
um because he's seen absolutely everyone
for it and had been looking for
uh the actors to play kamala khan for a
few years prior to casting me
uh so so yeah i would say that he's like
the
you know guy and is it like
animation voiceover where it's you in
front of a microphone or was it
motion capture performance
so captured on that mocap stage with
with all my
amazing cast mates and got the head jam
i got the mic
i got everything and when you do stuff
like that i mean we've all seen like
behind the scenes videos and stuff
but everyone just flat out acting as if
or make him pretend as if you were
making a tv show
or a movie it's just like the the props
aren't necessarily there the set
isn't necessarily there but your
performance
you have to emote because there's
cameras all over your face is that right
main difference um me was pretending as
if i didn't have
all of that gear on my body and all
those dust on my face
and pretending that like a pool noodle
is really
like a whatever like a action
thing so that mocap stage
is really spectacular in that you get to
play in this playground of
um your imagination it's nothing but a
padded
now if you if you're acting with people
in a scene
are they there with you or is everybody
shot separately
[Music]
because my scene can be totally changed
by
a glance that nolan north will give me
or
or any of my other actors in a scene
with me so
everything um that you see two people in
there are actually two people
uh you know of course unless it's just
me standing on top of a
roof talking to myself uh so tell us a
little bit about about your life before
this
like where where you from what your
parents do
what's your sign all of that
um i'm a cancer no um i
i am a first generation american myself
i'm uh egyptian american
both of my parents are immigrants from
egypt um
they are not um artists at all
um my mom like studied philosophy and
you know i was gonna be a teacher and
everything and
um i don't know any other egyptian
artists really i really had to look for
him
everyone i know whose egyptian is a
pharmacist
so uh i knew right away
as soon as i knew what an actor was i
knew that i wanted to be one
um i think i was like three or something
when my mom explained to me
what an actor was and and when i learned
i was like okay great i'm gonna walk
around the house playing pretend and i
never stopped
and um i quickly as soon as i could get
some education
on what an actor was and i sing as well
so
um i got that education as well and i
started auditioning as soon as i could
so have the conversation with your
parents go
um having a little bit of experience
with immigrant parents
my dad i'm first generation my father's
side saying like
i want to make movies for a living isn't
always well received
right um of course my mom wants
to make sure that i had an easier life
than she did
and every every parent wants that for
their kid right and
saying that you want to be an actor is
not
exactly uh uh
something that makes your parents feel
very secure in your future
uh so she of course was like are you
sure are you really really sure are you
really sure
and like even up until now she's like
what's your plan b c
d e f um but i'm i'm very gung-ho and
have always been so
um when she she she realized that
earlier on
but um now especially after this game is
coming out and
she's seeing like that there's an la
times article about me and there's this
and that and cnn and all this she's like
okay this is real the all right cool
good for you
follow your heart sweetheart um my mom
is is proud of me and and she's happy
that i'm happy
and i think that's that's ultimately the
most important thing and
she knows that i work too hard to not
take care of myself so
now when you got the role were you
familiar with the character of kamala or
no
kamala sorry my bad there you go kevin
yeah i know right
damn it um and i used to like i've
always known her as
as kamala since the character was
created but now
the introduction of the future vice
president has really thrown my
pronunciation for a loop
but were you familiar with the character
when you got the gig or did you have to
go
reading books i mean was there even like
she was in a cartoon somewhere was there
even a reference for you to look at
yeah there were comics um i had heard
about kamala khan
before but you know there are a ton of
people who are
of the they think that she is carol
danvers
right because there's captain marvel and
there's miss marvel
and and i think i at some point may have
been
in that camp or but i i knew that i had
heard of kamala khan
um in some way or another but when i
got the scripts for the first time um
you know it's marvel so it's very
secretive and they took out all of the
names they took out all the indicators
that this was a marvel project
i thought i was i thought i was
auditioning for like a web series at
some point like i couldn't tell you what
it was
um i was like this is like a high budget
web series like what is this
uh but of course like they took words
out like mjolnir i thought
instead of tony stark i thought i was
talking to a dude named tom
uh so i i didn't i had no
no no uh idea what it would be for but
i got to then get to know the character
for who she was
um without fangirling over the fact that
she's a superhero
um because of course like if i knew that
before i went in
i'd be like oh okay okay she's a
superhero like let's read everything and
it was important for me not to do that
in in that time and to just get to know
her for the
exuberant bubbly wonderful girl that she
is and uh
and then quickly i as soon as i found
out i was like great i'm gonna go to a
comic book shop i'm gonna grab
everything i can
physically and then i met the marvel
guys and they were like hey you want
let's get you marvel unlimited and i was
like oh i'll
deep dive uh so but i think
everyone on the game was you know quick
to remind me
that i'm already a lot like kamala khan
and
that i didn't need to do too much of a
deep dive into it and that
you know we are creating our own crystal
dynamics version of the character
and of the story so uh i got as prepped
as i could
when now so everyone's playing it now
just came out right this came out uh the
fourth
when did you uh shoot your performance
saundra
we started well i started with the cast
um i would say spring of 2018
um and we did the mocap yeah i know i
know we did the mocap maybe probably
like once a month every month
um for a while but crystal and marvel
had been working on it
for long before that um i remember sean
our director telling me that they were
looking for kamala khan for at least two
years
the actor to play her so yeah
it's been a while have you gotten to
play the game or do you at least
watch all the cut scenes i'm just
now starting to see all the cutscenes of
course it's been a couple years so i'm
like okay what oh
what in order what in what order is what
uh but i did get to play a little bit
and uh it's it's really fun kind of like
viscerally like feeling uh smashing
two bots together and everything through
the controller
uh so i dig it it's fun were you a gamer
before this
i was a gamer when i was like four
[Laughter]
my mom got a sega genesis like when i
was super super young
and she i was like what it what is this
i'm like i think i was like two when she
got it
uh and she was like okay great i'll play
so i think she was she was more the
gamer but
definitely like sega um
what was like sonic the hedgehog and
aladdin was my deal
but now things have progressed and i'm
starting to catch up i loved that
aladdin game that that 11 game was
actually quite magical
i played it that was one of those was it
a whole new world so damn good the
graphics were amazing
um you went to uh new york comic con
last year right i remember seeing some
some footage and some images of you on a
big ass stage
madison square garden hell yeah oh my
god
i imagine your first like
announcement ever being at the madison
square garden
i was like yo zeppelin's been here are
y'all sure
uh it was a big deal and so
well received nobody knew that kamala
would be in the game until
that announcement and i i heard
while i was off stage and they brought
up my trailer
i heard people screaming and like
sobbing
in the audience and i got to meet these
people in person and that was really
special of course that's what i'm
missing now with the whole like
stay-at-home deal but um but yeah
meeting them
was was really really cool yeah i have
to imagine that there's
you know it's not even i have to imagine
i know that there are
an entire generation of young brown
girls who've never seen themselves at
the center of a video game like this
how has it been interacting with them
even virtually the way that you have to
given the world that we're in you know
what is that what does that
responsibility feel like but even just
what does that energy feel like
it's really special um because i've
never i haven't had that
growing up so knowing that it is
now happening in such an amazing way you
know she's not
a background character who's you know
got
a line or two um and that would be cool
i would be excited about that
but they they're doing what i thought
was the impossible
by putting this like young brown girl in
the forefront and she is powerful and
and i'm now playing this this
brown lead and i of course i was like
that's not when's that gonna happen um
and now it did
and for for girls for young girls to see
that
this is possible that you can be
portrayed
in a powerful way um but also a very
real way like she's a
she's a spunky girl she's got a fun
personality and
you know and she's a fan girl which
we're all fangirls uh kevin i've seen
you fangirl over rogan before like
we all do that so to be able to relate
in that way to such a powerful role
is is really important and i i'm now
seeing
people like hit me up on twitter and
instagram and and i i just can't believe
it
that that like la times article came out
about
um representation and kind of my
experience with
auditioning for roles that i i did not
feel comfortable with playing
and i was kind of worried at first
because i was like well you know i don't
want anyone to think that like
this is you know like problematic or
whatever but then
immediately i started getting all these
actors
um like these brown actors or these like
actors of color
hitting me up to say thank you for being
loud about this experience that we are
all
having but are too afraid to talk about
um so
it's just been it's been really awesome
to
hear that people are relating and uh and
to see this amazing character be in the
forefront
um the uh you mentioned before man the
the la times piece
would be insanely impressive uh to the
parents man mom was
very very happy about that i take it
yeah that's what did it in for
uh i had a photo shoot with them and i
wore a dress that she bought me
so she was especially happy about that
she's like oh your makeup looked good
thanks mom uh
yeah that's what did it in for her she
was like wow the whole
city of l.a is going to see this and she
shared it on her facebook and
like her sister called her it was very
exciting
adorable um what's what's on the horizon
for you what uh what's next i'm hoping
that this experience will open some
doors
and allow you to play roles that you
might not have been offered before
yeah i'm i'm really excited
that these roles are now starting to
become available
um and i'm looking forward to playing
more of them
as far as right this moment i'm just
auditioning
and i'm writing like i'm writing stand
up and i'm
like recording an album with my band
mate so like right now i need to stay
creative
uh while we audition stand up
yeah that's my like quarantine like the
thing i'm trying to do
is it really so that's that's i've never
that's fascinating like
like uh well we're trapped from the rest
of the world i think i'll become a
stand-up comic well done
nobody picks that route man and the lord
knows we need more stand-up comics right
now
um i tried to like a zoom for a benefit
show and i was like i know this is not
the right way to go but what else have
we got let's go
good for you man um that's tremendous
and now this is the worst question that
any creative gets
especially when they're out promoting
something like when's the next one
like do they did they tell you like
we'll do this again and you're coming
back
like now you're a part of the team or
something like that or is it like
uh right now they're now that nobody's
talking about
a future yet i don't know dude your
guess is as good as mine man i'm
i'm just home auditioning we'll see
i would i would like to hope that the
reception for the game will inspire
marvel to perhaps do more with kamala
khan going forward and then maybe
i mean you've got experience you're the
voice you know you've done
you put your time in you know some [ __ ]
about it i mean
it's it's being it's being well received
this is only the second day of uh after
the release so
uh we shall see but of course fingers
crossed i would love to
do this soon tremendous congratulations
uh sandra that's really really cool man
uh and welcome
welcome to the marvel universe uh as a
guy who was once mentioned in a marvel
movie
welcome to the marvel universe and as a
guy who've seen them all
come aboard we're expecting you thank
you guys so much it's so nice to meet
you
oh thank you for taking time out stay
cool
bye bye bye how awesome man
great her whole career out of her me and
you we're done
yes her downhill from here beginning
huge role to begin
with too that's it's crazy like when we
were kids
you know nobody was like oh i i i was in
pitfall
you know what i'm saying i'm pitfall
harry you know yeah i'm the dude i'm who
you've been playing
but it's so strange that there's now a
world of performance
that is like uh-oh what happened oh
do we take a little crap are we off the
air
we still live we're in it hey
that was scary for one second we didn't
exist when we weren't relevant it's like
we were suddenly in the matrix
uh man that's cool good for her
yeah and it's you're right like there's
there's now a job
that is being in video games and acting
and acting in vietnam like just not just
being the body not just being the voice
but like
you're sitting there going like doing
this [ __ ] with your face
trying to cognize why modoc is trying to
kill you
totally even though he's not there he's
a pool noodle as we just heard
you're full on andy circusing it really
man she's a modern-day andy circus
hell yeah andy circus gave that [ __ ] up
he's like i'm an actor now
i was an actor then but now i'm on
camera i'm in batman
yeah now i'm alfred he was so good in
[ __ ] black panther too
oh remember when he's like cuddle fish
oh you wanna hit my mixtape black
panther that might have been in civil
war that way he does the cuttlefish bit
was the civil war no i don't know he's
not in civil war
i know he is foreign yeah that was where
you first meet him right
right um all right well send him a link
to the sound cloud
we have some uh news we do have some
news that's why we get together kids
to find out what's going on in the world
mark bernard got us some news hit us
with some news
um there was a there was a new story
last week that started very vague it was
um the batman production has shut down
because an unnamed crew member has
tested positive for the coronavirus andy
circus
no and you know clearly like that
verbology sort of makes it seem as if
like oh no it's one of the guys who
works on the lights or it's so many
craft services and they're really
concerned or whatever
no it was [ __ ] batman batman himself
[ __ ] batman himself hanging out with
the bats too when is he supposed to beat
the riddler
catwoman and the penguin if he can't
even beat covet
i mean there's there's a case now for
the full face mask
i think um
how is he doing this is serious man it
is serious we we are making jokes but
it's
you know clearly not the only famous
person
to have coveted this week i know the
rock at least revealed that he and his
family
had been diagnosed and say something if
they can get the rock
they can get us all yep that covet's
coming man
when i heard my wife came in my office
like as if it was i was
[ __ ] perry white and she was lois
lane she's like
the rock has coven i'm the rock great
caesar's ghost
yes kill the front page story i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it is one of the
healthiest people in the world
literally the healthiest person i've
ever seen it comes for us all the time
it comes for us all but yeah there's
there's no word on how he's doing
uh except that he's isolating in
accordance with established protocols
um but hopefully he will recover he is a
young man
in relatively good health yes michael
rooker
just talked about having it really as
well yeah the great michael worker who i
worked with in mall rats
um but of course we all know as yondu
indeed from uh guardians of the galaxy
amongst in many other roles um he uh
i guess did a facebook posting where he
talked about he had it and he
waited it out and uh wrote it out in a
winnebago of sorts like like an
airstream trailer or something on his
property
um he didn't take any of the medicines
right
he said he just tought it out him and
his immune system
it's a big deal because michael's no
spring chicken he's 65 years old
indeed and you know they told us in the
beginning of this like
old people are very susceptible older
people instead
but he happily reported that he kicked
this thing's ass
good yeah so yeah it's you know it's and
as we saw tom hanks
and freda wilson they had it and got
over it so it's yeah i just
i saw that tiffany haddish just tested
she got to confess it to dr fauci
himself really yeah like i think there
was some
you know entertainment medical coalition
you know everybody should wear a mask
thing and she's like i got it too
so she has it currently um i'm not sure
i'm not sure if she
the i got it too i feel better
when famous people get it because then
it's like well
they made it through right you know what
i'm saying like when tom hanks made it
through i'm like all right well maybe
we'll all make it through same with rob
pattinson i'm like you know he'll make
it through
because he's batman and then we'll all
make it through but i think we're we're
currently seeing this
this this wave of all right guys let's
get back to work we're going to start
production again we're gonna finish
this thing might be too soon and then
three four five days later
uh we're gonna pull the plug we're all
gonna kind of go back and figure it out
because
you know somebody's got the rona and
somebody tested positive and
you know it's this this weird the the
stutter of we're trying to go back back
we're not going to do it
i mean we all want to go back to work
but maybe it's just too soon and where i
mean
like that's your that's your leading man
presumably in almost every scene in the
movie
yeah so that means everybody that he
worked with in that time or was around
they got to get tested and stuff like
that yeah
it's a he's a good actor man like you
watched that lighthouse picture
i did not you didn't say it no it's
worth watching is it yeah he's good he's
good in good time he's he's a really
good actor he's
i think he's a good choice for for yeah
no i'm not bored
he's making i don't know about batman
but for the batman
put an article in front of it that's
pattinson's a batman
he is a batman well we wish uh rob
pattinson well get better batman
speedy recovery we're all [ __ ] team
edward here old chum
damn it and we want to see you back in
the saddle and stuff
um because that that tiny taste of a
trailer
it's not going to hold us all for a long
time i need it in my face yeah
constantly um all right feel better rob
pattinson feel better the rock
feel better michael rooker tiffany
haddish god there's a new category on
the show new
the new subject yeah who famous has
covered this
deli careful out there kids wear your
masks
near as i can tell john boyega does not
have the kovid
um nor does he seem to have very much uh
segue
segway uh nor does he have anything he's
keeping
too close to the vest saw this saw this
you know and put it on front
street about star wars we did yeah it
seems that we're we're in an era
where people uh are out of [ __ ] to give
about what used to be
considered he's off the clock son yes he
was on the clock for
you know how long years six years or
whatever yeah
2015. now he's off the clock and he's
attacking the block
he's very much attacking the block um he
came i thought what he said was
like interesting i was like wow
yeah i hadn't thought about that none of
it none of it feels
uh from uh from a mean place no it
doesn't feel like he's just like
burn it down or anything like that yeah
i think it's he just has a
as as a guy who was a ground zero for
all the star wars stuff
indeed he has an absolutely valid take
he does and
based entirely on his experience um in
making star wars movies you know for
british gq for their september cover
story
he talked about his experiences making
those movies and and being part of
both the marketing engine as well as the
production machine
because remember he is the first image
that we saw in the trailer
the force awakens the very first image
that they
showed us for this brand new star wars
trilogy
was uh a black storm trooper in the
middle of a desert remember how striking
that image was and how everybody was oh
what the
so yeah he was the not only was he used
in marketing
he was the he was the face pin of morgan
if you remember the end of that trailer
there he is holding the lightsaber in
the snow and we were all like holy crap
we know what this movie it was very much
this is not your father's star wars yeah
you're changing some [ __ ] up
and uh and so he talks about sort of
it's very difficult to maneuver um you
get yourself involved in projects and
you're not necessarily going to like
everything
but what i would say to disney is do not
bring out us black character market them
to be much more important in the
franchise than they are and then have
them pushed to the side
it's not good i'll say it straight up
imagine all that with an accent um
and like more handsome than i am
it's a matter of opinion mark well you
know it's the accent though that's
the accent is empirically true um
you know and talks about how the other
people of color in the cast
felt that they suffered the same
treatment kelly murray [ __ ] tran and
naomi aki who was in um rise of
skywalker
and even oscar isaac but he referenced
like
um like kylo and
daisy and and he didn't say their names
he says like you you guys knew what to
do with daisy ridley you knew what to do
with adam driver you knew what to do
with these other people but when it came
down to keller marie tran
when it came to john boyega you know
[ __ ] all so what do you want me to say
what
what they want you to say is i enjoyed
being a part of it it was a great
experience
nah nah nah i'll take that deal with
this great experience
that's not even his accent i don't know
where that was
they gave all the nuance to adam driver
all the nuances this is the linos
do this again slow yeah they gave all
the nuance to adam driver
all the nuance to daisy ridley let's be
honest daisy knows this adam knows this
everybody knows i'm not exposing
anything
i'm the only cast member who had a
unique experience with that franchise
based on their race
let's just leave it at that it makes you
angry with a process like that
it makes you much more militant it
changes you because you realize
i got given this opportunity but i'm in
an industry that wasn't even ready for
me
nobody else in the cast had people
saying they were going to boycott the
movie because they were in it
nobody else had the uproar and death
threats sent to their instagram dms and
social media
saying black this and black that and you
shouldn't be a stormtrooper
nobody else had that experience but yet
people are surprised that i'm this way
that's my frustration wow
yeah i mean there is being honest you
know
it's and and it seems as if everybody
who saw those movies
could see that the
the filmmakers were not that interested
in developing story for finn
um some filmmakers had been like there
was
you know when when the colin trevorrow
draft began to leak out there
including some like concept art for what
the sort of final chapter was going to
be
and very much of it was finn leading
like a stormtrooper rebellion
on a on a death star and like let that
character's evolution sort of begin
and and reach its its natural climax
right but
that wasn't good that was in the colin
trevor adrian yeah that's a cool idea
um but uh but it seems as if you know
jj and even to his credit he's like i i
will defend jj like i love jj and what
he did with that last movie was
miraculous but the the the
franchise itself was not that interested
in centering finn
in its drama um and he says that not at
the expense of daisy ridley or adam
drivers like no
sure that story is clearly a story that
you want to tell but don't
don't cloak yourself in in
the progressiveness of casting this this
actor
in this role and then don't do anything
with him
what is the what would you say his
parallel
was his character to the original
trilogy
he's not luke that's days that's
ray yeah he's wedge
more screen time than wedge but he
survives all the movies
um has slight impact on the plot he's
not even han
no oscar isaac if anybody's han it's
oscar isaac and even he
does get sort of diminished by he's not
princess leia
i guess not i mean you thought there
might have been like you though there
was gonna be a whole romance between
daisy and
and and no but i mean in terms of like
if everyone had a parallel like if da
if rey is luke and
uh driver poe is han
right and driver is vader and driver is
vader then
i guess is yeah i guess if you had to
slot him into an original paragon
it's and he doesn't even have that
arc no it's either that or it's obi-wan
and he's not obi-wan he's not obi-wan
because he didn't have an obi-wan in
these movies
i mean maz kanata was sort of well you
know
han solo is obi-wan zolo's the guy who
kind of swims in and
oh luke luke was obi-wan yeah we're
sitting here going who was the
this is [ __ ] literally a hermit on an
island drinking
blue titties in the first movie it's han
because han dies like han dies
to propel your heroes onto their next
stage and then the second movie it's
yeah
clearly he's the he's the ghost of his
former self like a force ghost on
dagobah
i'm uh look i i i would not have done
as good a job as any of the directors
did on
star wars the new star wars as ryan or
jj i'm not
nearly as talented as those guys uh that
being said
it does seem like there were a lot of
missed opportunities
with finn yeah like we were you the one
that pointed it out when we were doing
the
review somebody remember i talked about
it i know it wasn't my idea i thought
it was yours where they could have like
just
like the what was the late the girl he
met yeah the naomi aki character and she
was like we used to be
storm troopers too and then that was a
that was a jc
was it a jc thing yeah that if that if
he just said
if she just said we did it because of
you finn we heard your story
and we were inspired by you that
that would have like really just brought
his ark home
yeah one line that's it that's all you
need
i mean or an entire actual story line
where the character's got a that would
have been better
but if you're not going to do that but
at the end there could have been a
little
something but even even then there was
like so that the
climax of this story required him to be
part of it
yeah it's true because they could have
made this movie without it they didn't
need to be finn at all
and everything kind of would have
happened the same way
um he's a good guy i met him at the
premiere nice to meet you
and uh you know it's good for him for
putting his truth out there
yeah i mean i think he you know he's got
a story to tell he's got a story to tell
and the
the rest of the cover story is very much
about this moment in history
you know in the wake of a star wars
being this giant event in his life
right and the sort of black lives matter
protest in london and this big like very
moving speech he gave
um which apparently was off the cuff you
know not a plan thing at all
in which he was a little fearful for his
career right by coming out and saying
things
and all these directors you know then
champions like i'll work with you in a
heartbeat john
you're amazing john but i think he is
he's now reached the
i'm out of [ __ ] to give let me just
tell my truth because what else do i
have at this point it's going to power
them man
they'll empower them in a big bad way
absolutely
um good for him getting it out there
totally and it doesn't seem like it's
bitter
because it doesn't and like you know of
course the inner the bitter side of the
internet is like you should be
thankful that you got that job and it's
like well
it always looks grass is always greener
from the other side of the fence clearly
you know he's expressing that it wasn't
what you think it could have been or
should have been or was
for him it was sounds like like you know
as much as like
oh man i got to be in a star wars that
it's a bit of a disappointing experience
yeah i mean and he he does acknowledge
that it was an amazing opportunity and a
stepping stone that has precipitated
quite a bit of good
in his life and his career but he's also
excited
and relieved to be able to get this off
his chest yeah
and he had to take so much [ __ ] they
went after him online and [ __ ]
yeah um all right well good for him
good for him what else we got um sony
uh is is in the process of capitalizing
on the marvel characters that they
control basically all of which spin out
of the star
the spider-man universe um and so now
they're looking to set up a suite of
marvel tv series
um probably at amazon
yes i wonder how kevin feige gonna feel
about this
you know it's uh he just got all the
marvel tv
into one place coming up yeah and then
the analogy that at least deadline who
broke this story
is using is the defenders basically like
yeah that's what it sounds like
yeah like we'll do three or four maybe
five different series that will build to
a thing
and this is at amazon um it is currently
still being developed internally
at sony pictures tv any ideas what
the shows might be the first one seems
it's going to be
silk um which is an adaptation
of uh comics the character that's spun
out of spider-man
korean-american female comic book
superhero was created by dan slott
and artist humberto ramos um
and i think that the the hope is that
this entire suite will kind of be
overseen
by phil lord and chris miller oh good
who have signed an overall deal at sony
tv and clearly they know their way
around a spider-man universe
um so so yeah i mean it
they're currently putting together their
pitch in their suite then they're gonna
take it out to a bunch of various
streamers most likely um it's possible
that it'll land on a
cable network first and then stream
after that but
if amazon or netflix wants to get back
in the marvel business
i wonder if netflix does it just to be
like
[ __ ] disney or if they're like look we
don't want to even play in that marvel
game no more
yeah like it's that that's a good pick
up for amazon though
it'd be a good pick up for apple yeah
you know like they could give them
the big bad identity man that's a big
shout out to the home of spiderman
shows not so bad um
but yeah what else could they do they
got the spider-man characters
i mean i think according to to this
piece she was also part of the new
agents of atlas team
did you ever read those books um
it was i think it was kind of like you
know
globe trotting international spies but
with superheroes in it
um jeff parker created uh the the sort
of
first wave of it got at this point now
like 10 years ago um
but it was just fun you know like just
good natured
kind of like what agents of shield is
but um a little bit more
um widespread i think and with actual
[ __ ] superheroes at its core from
jump
um so if that's part of where this
character has been in maybe they have a
claim to that title as well
um i mean i don't
know jay jonah jameson his own show
i mean you know what i'm saying i know
what you're saying
like there's there's there's a way and
nobody's quite
pulled this off yet but you could do a
kind of
show in the marvel universe like there
could be a lawyer show there could be a
doctor show
there could be a press show there could
be a hospital show
like you could do all of this stuff
you're like oh yeah no but jessica drew
is our lawyer and
you know [ __ ] night nurse is going to
be our doctor and
you know like there's no reason you
couldn't do like a [ __ ] barrel
procedural but in the marvel universe
with characters you already have that's
true so true
um give this man a job i'll do it sony
are you listening
lord miller feel like we got this email
me
uh what else we got um zack snyder's
army of the dead
you can't stop zack snyder he's on fire
right now apparently
aside from justice league snyder cut
that's forthcoming
uh he's got uh the army of the dead
movies he's gonna come to netflix gonna
be huge and this is a part of the
the dawn of the dead that he did back in
the day um i'm not sure they're not
they're not giving
too much information about it sarah
paulie in it
she is not in it right maybe it's not um
but amy the dead follows the aftermath
of a zombie outbreak in las vegas and
the group of mercenaries who venture
into the quarantine zone
do pull off a big heist and you know
what i'm bored you know what i'm saying
like
i'm i'm all for i can't wait to see the
snyder cut of justice league don't get
me wrong but
i look forward to zack snyder not
playing with superheroes because
one of his best films was the [ __ ]
zombie movie was dawn of the dead
and like i look forward to him going
back to this world and i appreciate i
i always like a good genre match yeah
and i love a good
space movie with a zombie i mean never
thought of that
that's pretty [ __ ] cool man and it's
one of many right like he's gonna do a
few of these they said there's a cartoon
series
right it's spinning off into an anime
series um as well as a prequel following
one character
a german dude named ludwig dieter
before the events of this thing and
they're shooting it in germany and i
think
it might even be in german language
because netflix is huge
internationally yeah and they're very
big on both international productions
and playing to specific audiences in
those years
and putting up like you know subtitles
yeah
so like it's super [ __ ] smart if
you've got an international cast that's
playing people from all over the world
just do [ __ ] movies on all of these
characters in that world where there
were already badasses
and also there's a company that's gone
like you know what
still some [ __ ] gas in the zombie
tank
and uh we'll take it from here amc like
it seems like they're stepping up to be
the next walking dead
for sure yeah no it's it's really it's a
smart play
um i'm in i can't wait when does it say
when it's happening uh
next year the movie's happening oh [ __ ]
you know what i watched
right before i came here i'm thinking of
ending it
the charlie coughlin oh netflix movie
i am not smart enough to understand it
from one viewing
it sounds cheery it's it
it's not not cheery it's not nice it's a
mind trip
though it's uh boy you want to feel
[ __ ] dumb
as not just as a human being but also as
a creative in this business
yeah i i i spend two hours and change
watching that and being like
yeah i've long admired that work and
also stayed a
bit away from it because it always like
sniffed the key new york
this is over my head and i think i'm a
relatively smart person and i
don't know how to feel i had to turn to
my wife to be like what happened
she explained it and i was like sounds
valid to me but uh i will rewatch again
some of the best writing
i've seen in the movie and yeah this is
dialogue
porn no i mean i loved being john
malkovich i loved adaptation
you know like there's he's he's
brilliant yeah
but it's sometimes it's a little like ah
the heat of your brilliance is making me
feel inadequate you gotta clear
a few hours for this because it'll a few
hours after the movie so you could sit
there and be like what did i just watch
yeah just to feel a different way uh
what else we got
um it has been a year since david
benioff and d.b
weiss the creators of ye olde game of
thrones oh they brought that
uh dragon in for such a safe five-point
landing
correctly they totally was very happy
with the end of
game of thrones they were it was game
over
we were all victorious i remember people
saying yes i think they were champagne
and laurels and they were like these
guys give them all the emmys
um they uh they've set their first
tv project at netflix and it's an
adaptation
of a chinese science fiction epic called
the three-body problem
which is the story of humanity's first
contact with an alien civilization
okay um benioff and weiss are not
necessarily running the show per se
um alexander wu who is the co-creator of
amc's the terror
infamy the season they did about the
japanese internment camps
is coming on to to write an executive
produce alongside the game of thrones
pair
ryan johnson you've heard of that fella
there's a guy who knows the thing about
telling a story
indeed um he's gonna mr brick himself
what's he been up to since brick mark
um you know he made a film called looper
and we've never heard of him since
looper is a good picture somebody should
take notice of that give him a big movie
like a star wars or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe you know
sometimes we come up with the good ideas
here
you take a flyer i'm not a kid um he's
gonna executive produce
um and plan b which is uh the company
run by brad pitt
um will also executive produce alongside
rosamond park basically
like they just got it's a hell of a
pedigree on that picture
in the series um i look forward to not
watching it when is it going to be uh
sounds too smart for me already uh it's
it's a ways away i mean they haven't
written anything they haven't shot
anything
they're literally just signing deals now
um but it's you know this
giant sprawling epic three
three books are in this series who's
doing it netflix
[ __ ] these streamers man they're
spending all the money you got to see
this [ __ ] ridley scott thing
i mean raised by wolves looks so
expensive it is it is the first arms
race that is actually benefiting us
yeah truly like they're all just in a
slugfest for our eyes
and they will spend ungodly sums of
money to win not
since the great cola wars of the 80s
crystal pepsi as the american public
benefited from two
warring titans and you know what i say
let them
fight the burger wars of the thoughts
that's true indeed um what else we got
um star trek i heard of it
yeah they're celebrating a star trek day
next week
why um basically i think it's like the
55th anniversary or something oh right
on of um
of the original series premiere but in
the wake of
every other virtual convention that's
been happening specifically
the fandom uh they're like let's do a
day also where we celebrate
all of our awesomeness on the internet
and i do got a few
star wars programs to shake a stick at
it's not just one thing anymore
no there's there's a good you know nine
different star trek shows that you could
find some way into talking about
um but one of the things they announced
in advance of that is that star trek has
cast its first
nine binary and trans actors for star
trek discovery
i'm right on you know well that's is
this who we're looking at
that's who we're looking at blue
delbario will make their screen acting
debut as the non-binary character adira
who's highly intelligent with a
confidence and self-assurance well
beyond their years
um and ian alexander will play the
transgender character gray
empathetic warm and eager to fulfill his
lifelong dream of being a trill host
means he basically has a slug inside of
his body that's also another
person right on starfleet
very inclusive very much so and it you
know it has always been like the galaxy
in the dna of star trek um has always
been diversity inclusivity
infinite diversity and infinite
combinations yeah um
and so for them to to make this
sort of push forward into that kind of
diversity is welcome
nice to see them uh staying on brand
absolutely
somewhere gene roddenberry would be like
right on
right on well done i won't make them
have any conflict because the future is
a conflict-free zone
but good vlania for bringing them in and
also like i left a pretty vagrant like
somewhere gene roddenberry
which presupposes he could be in hell
he's not
he's not kids gene rodney they'd never
take him in hell he'd go straight to
heaven because he came up with
star trek yeah that's that's a ticket
straight in
pretty much that's a get out of jail
free card right there indeed
um so yeah they'll be coming to star
trek discovery
i'm not sure if they are a part of the
third season or if they're being added
later
um but it premieres october 15th so
hooray
um what is the theme song to star trek
discovery
um i'm imagining there's some sweeping
strings and a horn or two
it's not they didn't do needle drop like
that one what was the star track where
they did a song and you're like what the
[ __ ]
enterprise yeah yeah yeah we're in space
[ __ ] it wasn't even about space it was
just like
the heart of a man or some [ __ ] like
that where like it was a diane warren
song which was basically just yeah it
was about the human spirit
we're like that's that's not very star
trek now the discovery theme like it
it it starts as if it feels like the
alexander courage but then makes a
couple of bobs and weaves but it feels
like so it feels like
[Music]
and when did that [ __ ] take over
[Music]
where'd they dump that [ __ ] man for a
[ __ ] march
those howls man that's star trek to me
ah
we talked about that there were lyrics
to that song right yeah remember
remember is that what it is
there are lyrics apparently we just
don't know them yeah nobody knows
i believe the last lines are remember me
they could
yeah it's uh it's a cash grab
oh he did it yes like the score existed
alexander courage was like i wrote your
theme song great
i would like 50 of the royalties on this
how do you get those
gene roddenberry as a television writer
write lyrics to a song
that will never be recorded it's crazy
so
every time it's played courage under
fire
damn man life uh what else we got
arnold schwarzenegger wants to make
television
oh that makes sense yeah everyone does
why not him
that's where all quality goes these days
to tv pretty much
um he is working with sky dance
television scott answer the same people
who made the last couple of terminator
movies
um and uh creator nick santora who did
scorpion previous to this
okay and it's a global spy adventure
with a father and his daughter
at the center of the story and that is
all of the specifics that anybody
has any any know anyone know where it's
going
um it is being expected to take out to
streamers shortly
there it is so this this feels slightly
like
news how old is he schwarzenegger
i'm not sure i think he's like seventeen
yeah i think he's like seventy
but uh this happens all the time in the
in trades where
here's a little bit of news that we're
also using as a uh
ringing the dinner bell to announce to
the town that we're going to be bringing
them something to see yeah no doubt
and yet i'm still really [ __ ] excited
to see schwarzenegger on television
it'd be better if he was like i'm gonna
play king conan
yes you know what i'm saying for sure
amazon's doing a king conan
series i'm returning to the role that
made me a star but i'm you know
old ass conan sitting on his throne and
[ __ ]
going on adventures um i remember
one of my favorite parts of true lies
which you know is a pleasant enough
movie a little
tonally imbalanced but it's that
charlton heston
is basically playing nick fury in that
movie
where he's got the eye patch and the
salt and pepper on the temples
and he's heading up an international spy
agency i'm like you know who'd also be
kind of awesome at that schwarzenegger
you know not that i need a non-sam
jackson nick fury but
the sort of grizzled old veteran of a
thousands
wars you've never heard of like a guy
who's expendable if you will
potentially expendable hmm
good for him getting that tv money man
indeed now we got to compete with the
likes of [ __ ] schwarzenegger yeah
tough to get a tv show now we're
competing against the terminator
very much so well may the best man win
may the young we're a man not a robot
from the future
no um and the other bit that i found
that reminded me of a thing that was
interesting in that news item was that
they're making a twins sequel called
triplets
that i forgot that they were making with
eddie murphy danny devito
and arnold schwarzenegger that's still
going forward apparently still going
forward
i'll watch anything eddie murphy does
but
so i'll watch that as well but it just
seems
i remember now it's all coming back to
me that's a hanging butt
yeah well i'd watch anything he does but
no i'm on board forever man [ __ ] his
christmas episode snl
still one of the most magical [ __ ]
hours hour and a half of tv
in the last 10 years man i i hope they
bring him back every year right before
christmas
that would be the gift that snl could
keep on giving indeed
uh what else we got tonight they're
re-airing the uh they're doing the
chadwick
episode which that sketch that we talked
about very briefly the blackjack pretty
sketch
jumped like went viral and it's now up
to like 23 million
views wow prior to this it had been like
well prior to his
untimely passing it had been like maybe
two three million views
or something but it's so damn endearing
and such a funny sketch and he's so
wonderful in it
god yeah it's been one week since he
lost
the black panther himself um my favorite
um
new story that came out in the in the in
the intervening time
is that his hometown in south carolina
wants to pull down
their confederate statue and put up a
statue of chadwick boseman that's
awesome like you know what
yeah i backed that i mean i was 100 for
taking out like a veteran statue
like regardless but mark's like
now i could get behind taking down the
confederate statue
taking down all the confederate statues
and put up them all statues of chad
mcposure or
all marvel characters i mean i'm not
picky
you know that one makes sense because
that's his hometown but like you know
some other neighborhood
iron man totally who would fight this
[ __ ]
this i think we're on to something if it
was all superheroes
yes marvel superheroes and you know what
some dc you get batman super i mean
honestly
yeah we'll just make it wonder woman
she's huge right now
her cue rating is high yeah
basically based on like what the public
wants the only one would be terrible
being ant-man statue because
yeah it's all the time it's cheap yeah
very cheap it's for the cheap zone
they're like where you took down
the [ __ ] confederate statue you
didn't even put up a new marvel statue
look look closely they're like
oh it's ant-man you sons of [ __ ] lean
in
um did you know that would turn it from
a
confederacy to a pro-federacy
wow thank you why did that joke work
uh i think so thank you i thought you
were gonna go con like khan dash
federacy like it's a convention
you're lucky i didn't go it's coming
through now khan
khan khan confederation
yeah not to be confused with kamal khan
as played by sandra saad
yes um do you use the waze
the app of the waves i [ __ ] live
on waze even when i'm not driving i use
waze to get around my house
it's such an amazing speed trap in the
stairs tells you where the cops are
so i don't want to go up to my kitchen
mark if the cops are sitting there with
a radar gun
uh yeah no that could come in handy
exactly
for lots of different reasons are there
cops here not going that way
exactly i stay on my floor i'm not going
upstairs apparently
according to dc comics and waze's
official twitter until october 31st
drivers will be able to select the
batman the animated series protagonist
kevin conroy did a voice as the voice of
your ways oh my god why only till
a certain time why can't we have that
forever um well i think you could have
it forever but you only have until the
31st to download it i'm downloading it
oh my god i want that that's so much
better than the the
you know the random lady voice yeah to
hear batman telling you which way to go
go left set us in is that what is that
graphic up there well they'll also put
up
you can the riddler is the other voice
from the arkham uh
video games but you can turn your car
your card symbol
into the batmobile yeah i'm in wait a
second so kevin conroy
is the batman voice and the other voice
is a riddler but it's nobody
wally wingert from batman arkham asylum
and i'm certainly not saying
wally is nobody but i'm saying like
kevin conroy
has been batman for the better part of
my lifetime at this point
um you know so that's this is a
tall order to stand next to that guy it
is and they also come with apparently
like little playlists
um featuring memorable soundtrack cuts
from masters like hans zimmer
danny elfman and prince oh
yeah i want in this is all good it's all
good news
who's picking the riddler voice unclear
i don't even care like if it was like
and starring
you know [ __ ] uh brad pitt as the
riddler
the pitler like who would pick that over
batman
although if they got mark hamill as the
joker
then i would do that you're absolutely
right missed opportunity missed
opportunity yeah or like
saving some money oh good point good
point
um i'm totally [ __ ] doing the kevin
comrade batman yeah like i really
changed my life i rarely listen to the
voice on my ways i usually have that
muted but like i might
yeah [ __ ] yeah now i would use it to go
if i was going down the street to like
7-eleven
even if i knew the way i would be using
my ways just to have batman tell me what
to do yeah
i i feel like there was a time when sam
jackson did one
that i didn't download because i'm
almost positive he wasn't gonna curse at
me the entire time
like that's the version i want left
[ __ ] left
get these [ __ ] cars out this
[ __ ] lane
you got 500 feet [ __ ] slow down
remember i think schwarzenegger did it
too
yeah as a terminator he was like go
right
go left uh reach your destination
i'm i'm so down for that man i hope they
paid kevin conroy a bunch of money for
that too
pipes are golden and what else you got
uh the last
item is literally a thing that that
swung through my twitter
okay um from the blackish
uh writer's room twitter feed okay but
it was still of
an image of a character in a submarine
that they used i guess for
for you know an episode and they said
the submarine
is uh that we used was co-owned is
co-owned not was
is co-owned by george clooney and
richard kind
george clooney richard kind the actor
yes
the guy was like oh my god big bong from
[ __ ] bing bong
from from he owns a submarine with
clooney
i know they're friends yeah but like
wait they own a submarine they own a
submarine together
and i i
just like i have friends makes sense
batman owns a submarine
i have lots of friends some of them are
relatively well to do nobody's ever like
hey man
you want to buy a submarine together i
wonder how much that cost
i mean how much money does richard kind
have to be diving in on this
pun intended the the following tweet was
like and richard kind was there when we
shot
and said i shouldn't have spent all my
spin city money
on a submarine is that what he said
that's what he said that's pretty funny
but like i was just fly
i couldn't wrap my head around the fact
that
those two guys of all the things you
could have gone in together on
were like submarines guys we need a
submarine
must have been like when they were both
couple like you know [ __ ] hungry
actors knocking about
and [ __ ] and like if we ever get rich
one day we should buy a submarine
wouldn't that be [ __ ] cool
cut to dive dive
great lady down or like they were in
spielberg's submarine-themed restaurant
that he had in beverly hills
dive at dive and they're like wouldn't
this be cool to have one of these
the restaurant no the sub yeah one day
maybe i'll get on a tv show i'm testing
for this hospital i bought it with that
[ __ ] tequila money didn't he sell
like a
a booze company and made a [ __ ] small
billion dollars or something
yeah he does very well on a lot of
things that aren't
speaking of a billion dollars
congratulations to [ __ ] tyler perry
they just announced that he's a
billionaire
everyone criticized that dude from adeen
that dude was like i'm gonna keep
wearing this dress until i'm a
billionaire
and then that's that i mean he's got the
massive studio and all that
i've read an interview he just did where
he's talking about like
i own all the lights i own all the
cameras i own all the walls so that
means i make the lion share the profits
and he's like yeah because somebody was
like how do you get to a billion dollars
pretty damn awesome i mean it's you make
a thing that is indispensable in a place
that wants it yeah and atlanta is you
know
probably the production hub in america
at this point it's the vancouver of
america
and his studio is the biggest and the
best and the newest and the shiniest and
he's been shooting
he shot like four seasons of television
in the last month yeah while we were
quarantining yeah
um because he's figured out a way to do
it that's incredibly quick
he's turned it into a camp like
basically everybody comes to the yep
studio and nobody leaves
speaking right did you see that tom
cruise uh is renting a cruise ship
literally to house the crew for the
mission impossible movie they're
shooting
like he's putting the entire crew of the
movie on a cruise ship
and not a yacht like like a silver
princess cruise ship yeah like norwegian
lions
cruise ship he's brave at like
[ __ ] one's going near a cruise ship
during this [ __ ] covent crisis
yeah at like 700 000 of his own money
he's spending to rent this cruise ship
to house his crew can't take it with you
and i'm not saying tom cruise is
anywhere near death but he is getting
old so
why not spend it on something lavish
like that you know what
free publicity mm-hmm we know about it
now we're like the [ __ ] seriously so
they're all gonna live on a big old boat
yeah to finish up the production yeah
soul boat that's just so
glow uh that's isn't that coming soon
too we should be seeing a trailer
for coming to america yeah what the
movie yeah
which means we'd have to be seeing a
trailer soon ooh next week we're getting
a trailer for dune
do you know that for a fact yeah
september 9th i hear that
uh i read something that um was his name
stalin skarsgard
spent six hours a day getting into the
baron harkonnen makeup
i know right doesn't that make you
excited your skin
is like a treasure to me my baron i just
wanna spit
in your face just a little spittle
you're never going to get as brilliant a
line reading as that there's a little
spell this is a little spindle
um is that all the news that is all the
news mark did the news there it is
ladies and gentlemen jc
we know that there are people out there
we know that they want to ask us things
ask us the these questions three jc here
is the
uh this is the this year proprietor this
year bar
uh say hi to him they'll put a camera on
him any second now there he is
jason's in charge everything tonight uh
andrew's not here so jc has been running
everything solo
and not doing a great job because he
just got back to us
as opposed to staying on here um what do
we got tonight sir how has the chat room
been
uh chat room's been pretty good um
people are digging it i had an idea
though you said clooney sold
cos amigos for a billion dollars yeah
and ryan reynolds
deadpool just sold aviation gin for six
hundred thousand
we could probably do like three hundred
thousand if we did a
fat man beyond seltzer art seltzer
hard sell so you're out and we like run
it for a couple years and then
look number one i'm in but number two
did you say that george clooney made a
billion and ryan reynolds made six
hundred thousand six hundred
or yeah six hundred oh no six hundred
million
million 600 million ryan reynolds isn't
very good at this
sorry 600 million yeah that's what he
got for selling that
and the rich get richer [ __ ] i mean
we could sell
fat man seltzer for like four million
yeah
done and done fizzy pop done and done we
could sell it for
i mean who like was anyone really buying
the aviation booze and [ __ ]
he did commercials for it if i remember
yeah we don't have it here
i've never tried it but apparently 600
million
that seems like a lot for a thing that
other people also make
[Music]
i'm in the weed business i i apparently
i got into the wrong line of work man
[ __ ] should have been the booze
business anyway give us some questions
all right uh from jeremiah nations
okay um is interested in knowing
what writer and director would be best
suited to make a biopic
about the year 2020. oh my god what a
great question all right hit us again
what uh what writer and director would
be best suited to make a biopic
about the year 2020 uh
okay um what's the guy's name that does
black mirror
oh charlie brooker yeah fair
very very fair i i mean i don't even
know if he could capture this
uh the desolation um if not
him fincher
do you see the pictures for mank yeah
uh who do you think um charlie kaufman
could write it
charlie got him to write it um it feels
like charlie kaufman did write 20 20.
son of a [ __ ] part of me is like
soderbergh
because clearly he's already been down
this road a little bit yeah with that
what was it contagion contagion um
roland emmerich the disaster of 2020.
um irwin allen it's a little something
from
70s kids nice um
yeah like it's but i also get the
like armando iannucci yeah
let's add some levity to it to add a
little like that dark
satirical kind of comedy of errors
um that like veep is and and
in the loop yeah yeah that's my take
that's my go-to
i like it good job brooker and armando
you need to together
bring you 20 20. all right what else you
got question two
all right
okay
wow so many buttons prince gastronome
says he's getting married in exactly one
week so he's curious if there are any
fictional marriages
that you guys wish could happen
and wish that did not happen
so like jean grey and cyclops or okay
uh one that i wish
could happen meaning
two characters that i would like to get
married two characters that
never got together that you would like
to see
together and then two characters that
they did put together
that you wish they didn't like adam
driver and ray
okay so like raylo all right let's see
um who would i like to see hooked up
well bruce wayne slash batman because
finally he'd be happy right uh himself
he's gonna marry himself
yeah bruce wayne mary's batman who's
like i love you i love you too
um it wouldn't be selena kyle
not for my money um
hmm
i'm gonna go with uh and it couldn't be
wonder woman because she's a goddess
um
some i'm gonna go silver saint cloud
bruce wayne mary's silver saint cloud
and you know that was the story line
that i was doing in batman
the widening gyre um and he gets
like happy suddenly he's less interested
in
you know like fighting crime he's more
interested in his own personal
fulfillment so it'd be nice i remember
when
you know they showed him at the end of
the dark night rises and he was
with uh selena kyle is good for him man
this dude deserves a [ __ ] break
so him i'd i'd definitely put together
um who did they put together that i
would not have put together
um lois and clark
i think that always has to be like you
know they were married are they still
married in comics probably not
they got married at one point and i
thought that was kind of like you don't
do that you don't land that plane you
got to let it
soar forever will they won't they will
they won't they
um that's what comes to mind you
um yeah i feel the same way about peter
parker and mary jane watson
yeah you know like i don't i don't
there's something about the arrested
development of those characters that
understand the impetus to want peter to
no longer be a photographer at the daily
bugle and become a
college professor and he's happily or
unhappily married and like
i get it but i still always want to live
in the simpsons reality where like
he's always going to be 18. frozen in
time always a freshman in college like
he's
just yeah i get that you want to tell
the last story
or the first story but that fat middle
is where comics kind of live and
i don't need that much progress and also
it always feels better when it's
like the hero is romantically
unfulfilled because
like you know he's committed or she's
committed to the work
right like you always want them to get
close and then something tears them
apart yeah and then something forces
them together
and then something else tears them apart
like it's and i get that it's hard to do
that for 50 years
but at the same token those are when
those stories are the best true
um for uh for a
union that never happened that i wished
happened um
dom toretto and brian o'connor from the
fast and the furious movies
those two boys deserve to be happy
together
and one of them passed away and i get it
and that's sad
but before that happened like there
could have been a big
shiny wedding uh hashtag family
[Laughter]
even though you haven't seen those
movies i don't ryan james gave me
uh a full box set and hobbs and shaw
for my birthday and he was like please
watch them mark's right
so i will get around to watching him
soon but i got the reference
like captain america i understood that
um all right that's the second question
and i wish that luke and leia actually
got uh past that first
kiss that's where that was going right
they related whoa
things are weird down on the farm my
friend mark likes the strange
um han and leia i wish we'd uh
seen the wedding yeah he was always into
their romance and stuff i was glad she
didn't hook up with
well not her brother but uh with luke
like you know before she found out they
were before they found out they were
siblings
yeah thought ham was the better choice
that would have been a nice wedding to
see
right mm-hmm darth vader shows up
[ __ ]
han pulls his gun i'm just here to give
away the bride no he's just like i'm
here to eat he takes his mask off
everyone's like oh wow not the fish
no that's the guy that got burned on the
lava land
um all right last question evening all
right last one
kevin dye is interested to know i
thought that was a [ __ ]
request kevin die i'm like that's not a
question so much as it's annoying could
you put that in the form of a question
yeah will you die he uh he's interested
to know what classic movie plot you
would remake as a marvel or dc
movie with the heroes and villains so
you remake alien except the crew
are the guardians of the galaxy huh okay
all right um let's see
all right i got one do you i do go
um it takes a thief
with steve rogers and natasha oh
an old-fashioned [ __ ] hitchcock spy
kind of man with no name um
romantic thriller
let those two kids finally get together
i like it i'm gonna go with jaws
starring odin as quint
uh thor as brody
and loki as matt hooper
i will i would like to see that version
but i would like to see that version
of the loki sort of rep theater company
yeah from ragnarok from ragnarok
with matt damon playing loki we're
playing local we get two bikes
again quint i like that um
let me see hmm
the blues brothers okay but with
falcon and the winter soldier nice
nice buddy road comedy um
i'm looking for there's there's not a
good collection of bad guys
in the mcu animal house but all mutants
just yeah just grey malkin lane
because i do want to see like ocean's 11
but i don't want it to be the avengers
but i want it to be
like the bad guys version of that
like they got to steal mjolnir or
something oh that's hot like the
yeah the ravagers or the revengers
whoever the hell it is
um citizen kane with bruce wayne
nice citizen wayne
and at the end he just keeps zorro zorro
zorro oh my god what does that mean
[ __ ] awesome um yeah
all right that was a pretty decent list
you got any more um
bj and the bear but with uh with
lockheed and kitty pry
oh i'm in a man those two in a truck
girl in her dragon [ __ ] i'm driving
across the country
i'm in that's that's that's that's i
wish sony and amazon were doing that
[ __ ]
show give me that yeah right written by
created by mark bernard and phil lord
stolen from bj and the bear
evangeline uh is that it that's all i
got
three questions and we [ __ ] aced them
all
and that could only mean one thing it's
time to go back out into the heat ladies
and gentlemen
[ __ ] hey still hot out there
guarantee you did you have a good time
sitting here listening to me and mark
chit-chat
nice to get through no no deaths this
week thank heavens no death this week we
stayed online the whole time
yeah yeah and then jc did the whole
thing single-handedly man give it up for
jc well done give yourself a single
there
hero mission control you can't
you can't do it there we go a lot of
clicks there's too many clicks
to get there um the uh the
once again we got no home uh to do the
show
and without jc so thank you to jc and
the
scum and villainy cantina who every week
he makes everybody go wait outside while
we do the show in silence
right here in the main room it was never
quite as weird
as when we had four people in here yes
you know like it's either
let's pack a house or let's do it vacant
but four people
give it up for our one audience member
tonight
brett deacon ladies and gentlemen yes
given us uh
given us it's nice to have another warm
body in the room
it is you know the female chuckles yes
exactly you know you're doing well if
you get deacon chuckle over there
um and uh give it up to the dude on the
other side of the spit guard
without whom there is no uh fat man
beyond mr
mark bernardin i'm very happy to report
that i had to get a
another covet test another one for uh
uh josh roush's uh movie i'm gonna go do
part in tomorrow so before they let you
on set you gotta go get a test
and it came back negative excellent
you're gonna be an old hat at this still
not coveting yeah yeah boy i'm getting
it good but one day sooner or later man
they're gonna jam it up my nose and be
like
what'd you do what you got up there yeah
and i hope i'm as strong as michael
rooker
i am also afraid of the day when they
figure out you know
the the version of i'm selling my pee
because my pee is clean
drug testing somebody figures out like
listen man just
we got this nose off of a cadaver where
it has like for 100 bucks
just you know swab a fake nose oh ooh
i hadn't even thought of that i i'm
sorry
it'll happen somebody will figure out a
way to spoof these tests i mean
what do you say like you're going in for
a test and they go to swap you know he's
like no no not that one
swab this one yes close your eyes swab
away
they're like um do you take that from
somebody buddy
no it's my spare hey who knows
the nose nose there it is dad joke to
finish the nose
the nose plays um thanks for coming out
and hanging out with us uh on the
weekend ladies and gentlemen
talking about the things that make us
happy all these wonderful distractions
from the
fire that is 2020 ladies and gentlemen
um just if you ever if it ever gets to
be too much you just come hang out with
us here in the fact
indeed once a week we'll be here we'll
tell you cool [ __ ] that's on its way and
you'll be like oh all right you're so
[ __ ] bad
it's just a hot mess now but you know
maybe in six months i'll get to go to
them in the meantime you go watch some
lovecraft country
indeed go watch some raised by wolves go
watch some the boys
season two go watch mulan if you if
you're in the mood to spend that money
have you liked that thing we've seen
some stuff we can vouch for
indeed um and uh and you know what also
if you're sitting there and you're like
i don't wanna watch any of those things
i've got ideas of my own well you go
write some stuff man
just like he does just like i do go
create sometimes it's nice to just kick
back and be entertained
sometimes it's way more fun to be
entertaining so
if you feel remotely creative go go
right [ __ ] watching other people's shows
yeah go make your own show and if either
you are watching
and taking some [ __ ] if you're creating
some [ __ ] and you're also in a mine to
eat
something use the door dash fat man
offer code
five dollars off your first order no
delivery freeze
god he's good that's right don't forget
that code's fat man
f-a-t-m-a-n for five bucks off your
first order with doordash
uh zero delivery fees yes
and thank you to sandra saad for taking
time out of her hot ass
saturday night saturday of ice cream
socials
to come and talk about marvel's avengers
video game and kamala khan which you
could play right now
on any number of video game
consoles is that correct i believe it's
true there it is so yes so thank you
sandra
keep kicking ass well done kid yeah uh
that is fat man beyond for this week man
i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next week same
fat time maybe same fat channel
podcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
for the good of all cree
longa forever prospero forever
you